[Music]
let's do it
good morning John first thank you so
much for your video on Tuesday now of
course we both recognize that we never
want this channel to become like current
events and politics channel they also
think that you are very very good at
making that type of video and I came
away from watching it being like oh I
get things better
I'm done the thing that when we talk
about politics here on vlogbrothers that
we are just making it worse just
deepening the echo chamber that by
spouting my liberal viewpoints I'm
chasing off everybody who might disagree
with me and ending all opportunity for
discourse but look I am me I have my
values and I have my worldview and I
believe things like global warming is
caused by people and it will be one of
the biggest challenges humanity will
ever face together and it's ludicrous
that we spent so much time denying the
joy of marriage to people just because
of the people they happened to love and
just like I think the government
shouldn't have spent all those years
discriminating against people because of
their sexual orientation I don't think
that it should be legal for businesses
to do that and creating and feeding an
irrational fear of people who want to
come to America just like my ancestors
wanted to come to America because they
believed in the same dream that we all
believe in I think that's an effective
but dangerous way to gain power I
believe that these things are true and
that running the country while denying
them is a bad idea do I want to drive
away the people who disagree with me no
but that doesn't mean that I'm not going
to say the things that I believe I am me
and I'm here to be all the parts of me
that I want to be I'm here to be silly
I'm here to be thoughtful and I'm here
to use the platform that I have to fight
for the things I believe in not every
day but some days I'm not here to insult
the people who disagree with me because
like I want them to watch this more than
anyone when I see things that I believe
in like human rights and objectivity and
liberal democracy being threatened I'm
not going to not talk about that last
weekend I went on Twitter and I offered
to donate five dollars of the ACLU for
every person who submitted to me a
hand-drawn message of support for
immigrants and refugees I got over 2,000
submissions and some of them were just
way above and beyond just beautiful
pieces of art this weekend only so from
now until midnight on Sunday sometimes
I'm not sure which the artists of some
of those works are selling them as
posters at dftba.com as part of
president Trump's ban on all refugees
entering the United States federal
funding to local organizations that help
refugees find work and get training and
have access to like simple things that
they don't have when they arrived in
America because they basically have
nothing like toothpaste and tampons has
been eliminated it just doesn't exist
anymore and those organizations now are
not in a great place so not only have we
stopped helping people who want to come
here we've stopped helping people who
are already here that doesn't seem like
a good idea so a hundred percent of the
proceeds from the sale of these posters
is going to be divided up among a bunch
of different organizations that do that
very important and very good work
because look we can make a difference
and we can work for the world that we
want to see that isn't creating an echo
chamber that's creating change John I'll
see you on Tuesday